[Music]  what does Juanita moon sueño it means  little drink that's it no story alright  everybody sit down sit up it's a story  of a block that was disappearing and in  Baku it hold Washington Heights  the streets were made of music you  probably report some of famer greatly  exaggerated these blocks  you can't walk two steps without bumping  into someone's big plan  [Music]  I was saving upon my pennies in my piggy  bank is day this is gonna be an  emotional roller coaster the odds are  against you but there's a chance right a  [Music]  dream isn't some sparkly dynamic  there's no shortcuts sometimes it's  rough talking about kicking out all the  dreamers make some noise  we had to assert our dignity in small  ways just listen little details that  tell the world we are not invisible  ignore anyone who doubts you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you